Josh Horowitz you're a legendary
champion thank you for coming to help me
pack even though you're just a
journalist to interview me sometimes
you're my closest and dearest friend so
I'm happy you're here that's so sweet
man I mean I can only imagine how crazy
your schedules been it's got to be a
fantastic beast if you will don't make
bad puns like that Josh I'm gonna put a
hex on you okay yes I will hey Cimino
hexes have you noticed that weird reddit
thread that talks about you being an
actual wizard yeah isn't that ridiculous
because no one's an actual wizard
because magic isn't real Josh would you
get me my sex fetishes rave clothes okay
yeah you never know in Paris there's a
history out there I don't see how that
can possibly fit though man I mean I'm
no mathematician movie I liked it I
really I thought it was better you think
I was the best person in the movie does
everyone keep saying Jude Law do dolls
are we in two scenes so I don't even
understand how that makes any sense it's
not true
first of all and it's because he's
English but what did you think cuz I
want your honest opinion I thought Jude
was great but I thought you were great
too Jude Jude Jude oh wait hold on
forgetting my dog what about your dog
gotta bring my dog to Paris yeah you
can't pack a dog in the bag like that
very good okay but that you need like a
carrier or something not like said think
that's inhumane you know it would be
inhumane like on bringing my dog to
Paris it's okay please please don't or
you know it would be inhumane for
getting the food right or the bed that
would be inhumane
can I switch the water maybe can I get
like a glass you are drinking water Josh
no I've been drinking beer the whole
time it's always been water what are you
talking about it's not what the hell
that was not what you're saying Josh
that I'm truly a wizard that I truly
have dark wizardly powers that I made
some sort of deal with Baphomet in the
dark of the night
what was that are you implying perhaps
that I turned the scene-stealing Jude
Law into the little cute bitch he's
always been do you think I am in fact
the Dark Wizard fated to rule the world
lord over all the repugnant mortals like
yourself that's ridiculous
I would never do that I'm totally
kidding you got freaked out
you just got genuinely freaked out you
are kidding oh my god you got me again
are you always good judge how could that
not be a joke if it's literally insane
we're going pretty far on that we always
do and then I feel like there's always
this one moment where I look back and
I'm like oh my gosh josh is actually
scared right now I was I still am a
little bit of a shake Levi hey listen
what crazy idea you want to come to
Paris with me for this premiere stop it
don't be don't say stuff like that if
you don't mean it
well honestly I was just thinking about
it and I was like you know what I would
be way more comfortable on this press
tour if Josh Horowitz is with me cuz I
love you you know I love you I thank you
that's a yes you'll come that is a yes
and you're so excited I am so excited
and your neck pillow a delightful
beautiful neck pillow another great
adventure for Ezra Miller and Josh
Horowitz thanks buddy I'm really gonna
lean on you I have a propensity for
wordplay
you
[Music]